es gibt einen neuen Killer auf Amerika
Straßen
Fentanyl 50 Mal stärker als Heroin
alle sieben Minuten stirbt in Amerika
jemand an einer Überdosis Fentanyl
woher kommt es und was macht es so
gefährlich
die Spurensuche führt uns nach Mexiko in
drogenlabore mit tödlichen Chemikalien
hier herrscht das berüchtigte
sinaloa-kartell einer ihrer Drogenbosse
hat zugestimmt mit uns zu sprechen noch
auf der Fahrt vom Flughafen bekommt
unser mexikanischer producer einen Anruf
seine Leute haben ihre Augen und Ohren
überall sie beobachten uns er sagte mir
dass wir gerade über die Brücke gefahren
sind und genauso ist es
wir treffen den Mann den wir Horn nennen
sollen in einem Hotel gleich zu Beginn
macht er klar was Sache ist
solange ihr euch an das haltet was wir
ausgemacht haben dass Sie unsere
Identität verschleiert die Gesichter und
die stimmen dann ist alles gut wenn ihr
nicht schlecht über uns redet bekommt
ihr auch keine Probleme
und was genau meinst du mit schlecht
über uns reden
her also
[Musik]
ja das tun wir es ist ein Geschäft wie
jedes andere das nach den Regeln von
Angebot und Nachfrage funktioniert es
gibt welche die das Zeug wollen und
andere die es verkaufen so einfach ist
das
Fentanyl ist der neue Verkaufsschlager
der Kartelle das synthetisch
hergestellte Opiat ist die perfekte
Schmuggelware es ist leicht und
unauffällig zu produzieren und es macht
schnell abhängig
früher produzierten wir in riesigen
Industriehallen das war ein Fehler aber
wir haben dazu gelernt ein großes Labor
ist leicht zu entdecken sogar aus der
Luft und wenn du auffliegst ist sofort
viel im Eimer jetzt produzieren wir in
kleineren Mengen wenn irgendetwas
passiert rennst du einfach weg und lässt
alles zurück
Juan verlässt uns mit der Ansage so
lange im Hotel zu warten bis er uns
wieder kontaktiert
erst spät in der Nacht geht es los Horn
will möglichst wenig aufsehenerregen das
Kartell hat viele Feinde
er hat mir den Standort geschickt an dem
er auf uns wartet wir sollen an ihm
vorbeifahren dann hängt er sich an uns
ran und steuert uns per Telefon damit
uns niemand folgen
das Safe House liegt mitten in einem
Wohngebiet wir dürfen nicht von außen
Filmen die Nachbarn sollen keinen
Verdacht schöpfen
jede Nacht mischen horche und sein
Assistent anderes hier Fentanyl aus
Chemikalien die illegal aus China kommen
um zusehen zu dürfen müssen wir uns so
weit wie möglich vom Tisch entfernen
denn die Substanz ist extrem gefährlich
schon zwei Milligramm können tödlich
sein andreas hat das am eigenen Körper
erfahren
er ist ohnmächtig geworden und lag acht
Tage im Koma ich habe etwas von dem
pillenstaub in die Nase bekommen nur
wenig aber das reicht es ist so stark
in den USA wird eine Pille Fentanyl für
5 bis 10 Dollar vertickt allein horche
produziert 50.000 am Tag es ist ein
Milliardengeschäft für die Kartelle
Jorge bekommt ein reguläres Gehalt 3 bis
4000 Dollar monatlich ein Vielfaches des
mexikanischen Durchschnittseinkommens
wenn er seinen Job gut macht gibt es
einen Bonus dafür ist ihm jedes Mittel
recht
wir haben Leute die jede Charge für uns
testen sie nehmen die Pillen und sagen
uns ob sie gut sind das sind
Drogenabhängige sie sind glücklich weil
sie das Zeug gratis bekommen
hat er ein schlechtes Gewissen weil
seine Produkte Menschen schaden
ja es ist schädlich
klar kannst du sagen was ich mache tötet
Leute aber man kann auch bei einem
Autounfall sterben und wenn du das hier
richtig nimmst passiert ja auch nichts
wenn ich es als Konsument übertreibe
dann bin ich selbst für die Folgen
verantwortlich
[Musik]
Philadelphia USA hier herrscht das
Fentanyl es ist für 80% der Drogentoten
verantwortlich
der Stadtteil Kensington ist Drogen
Hotspot hier wird auf offener Straße
gekauft konsumiert gestorben
sarah ist der Hölle kensingtons
entkommen sie war fentanylabhängig lebte
auf der Straße vor fünf Jahren landete
sie im Krankenhaus und unfreiwillig im
Entzug
mit viel Willenskraft blieb sie danach
clean und hilft jetzt anderen abhängigen
mit ihrer Hilfsorganisation Savage
sisters
Vorbereitungen für einen Tag in
Kensington Sarah weiß aus Erfahrung was
die Menschen dort brauchen
dazu gehört Erste Hilfe Training im
Verhalten bei einer Überdosis viele der
freiwilligen Helferinnen sind selbst
noch nicht lange clean
ein wirksames Gegengift zu Opiaten es
kann bei Überdosis Leben retten
Kopf zurück und Knopf drücken
Aufbruch nach Kensington ich habe Hilfe
und Liebe im Gepäck sagt Sarah
sie gibt was sie kann weiß es reicht
nicht
kurz nachdem ich cleanbar ist Desiree
mit der ich die Savage Sisters gegründet
habe rückfällig geworden und gestorben
dann meine beste Freundin Claudia und
dann habe ich meinen Partner tot
aufgefunden
ich habe noch versucht im Naloxon zu
geben aber es war zu spät
alle mit denen ich 2017 den Entzug
gemacht habe sind tot ich habe so vielen
geholfen aber die Menschen die mir am
meisten beten konnte ich nicht retten
ein Park mitten in Kensington überall
Menschen deren Dasein sich nur um eines
dreht den nächsten fix
die Savage Sisters kommen jede Woche
hierher verteilen Hilfe solange die
Vorräte reichen
[Musik]
wir versorgen eure Wunden wir haben
Essen Kleidung saubere Nadeln Naloxon
Hygieneartikel
[Musik]
Fentanyl ist stärker und tödlicher als
vieles andere oft wird es anderen Drogen
wie Kokain mess am Vitamin oder Crack
beigemischt ohne dass die Konsument
innen es wissen die Händler steigern
ihre Verkaufszahlen dadurch dass die
Wirkung ihres Stoffs noch intensiver
wird
es ist eine Abwärtsspirale ohne Boden
sarah ist es wichtig den Menschen ohne
Urteil zu begegnen
es ist gefährlich hier wenn du auf der
Straße lebst als Frau auch als Mann die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass du ausgeraubt
verprügelt erstochen angeschossen oder
vergewaltigt wirst ist extrem hoch
jeder dir die begegnet hat ein
Hintergedanken in der Regel nichts Gutes
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass wir
einfach nur kommen und sagen hey wir
sind für dich da wie geht es Dir wir
haben dich lieb
in der Schlange treffen wir matt der
37-Jährige hat eine klassische
drogenlaufbahn hinter sich Alkohol mit
13 Kokain Crack dann über das
Schmerzmittel Oxycodon zu Opiaten
7 Monate war er clean dann griff er doch
wieder zum Crack es war mit
fentanylgemischt
ich wollte kein Fentanyl mehr nehmen es
macht mir Angst weil es so viele
Überdosen gibt außerdem ist mein Bruder
gerade gestorben an Alkohol was passiert
dann mit meiner Mutter wenn ich auch
noch sterbe
bei den Savage Sisters holt er sich
etwas zu essen und frische Kleidung
alles was er hatte wurde ihm geklaut
hier draußen schneiden sie dir die
Hosentaschen auf und den Rucksack von
der Schulter sowas wie Anstand gibt es
da nicht ich klaue auch um zu überleben
ich will es nicht rechtfertigen aber ich
stehle wenigstens nur von Geschäften
nicht von anderen Leuten oder meiner
Familie
in Kensington herrscht Gesetzlosigkeit
die Polizei hat den Kampf längst
aufgegeben
sie patuliert greift aber nicht ein in
den offenen Handel und Gebrauch
illegaler Substanzen
plötzlich bricht Hektik aus was ist los
eine Überdosis
die 25-Jährige natascha ist mitten im
Park umgekippt bewusstlos
Sarah handelt schnell
auch jetzt stehen die Polizisten
handlungslos daneben und damit
stellvertretend für ein ratloses Land
dem die Drogenwelle längst über den Kopf
gewachsen ist
die Substanz die Horn in Mexiko tausende
Kilometer entfernt zusammenmischt tötet
hier in Kensington jeden Tag Menschen
und es werden immer mehr
natascha ist wieder aufgewacht dem Tod
von der Schippe gesprungen
doch damit beginnt für sie der
Teufelskreis wieder von Neuem
ich weiß nicht wann es soweit ist es
könnte schon beim nächsten Mal sein
manchmal habe ich Angst aber oft bin ich
so deprimiert dass ich meinen Freunden
sage hör zu wenn es eine Überdosis ist
gebt mir keiner Loxone bitte lasst mich
einfach gehen dann habe ich endlich Ruhe
[Musik]